hello freak [ __ ] so what was it an
award over here what was it like having
and having him on here by the way Alex
Jones it was a dream come true like
sitting face to face and job as I'm him
talk well I've been friends with him for
a long time right on that guy since 1999
I think okay it was fun it was fun for
me but it was also something like for
the longest time people thought I was
avoiding having him on for some reason
and he kept saying well I try to get a
hold of Joe Rogan every my time in town
but he blows me off
he was always texting the wrong number
he's always like he didn't get worried
get a hold me that day and I'm like dude
I already have a podcast schedule I
can't do it today well I'll be back soon
when I'm back we'll figure it out we'll
figure it out then he would go on a show
Joe Rogan's been avoiding me I've been
trying to get in there to give out this
information it's very important
maybe scared maybe he's been threatened
the government threatened him he won't
open up about Bigfoot I believe Joe
Rogan did experience Bigfoot he saw he
was there in the woods
I was ultimately believe in Bigfoot I
guess who knows what he's got a high
fidelity prize I know you believe he
seems to believe in demons these days oh
yeah well they are demons they are
they're all they're all demons from hell
all of them they're damned they're
damned I'm sorry and if your red thing
we doesn't you apologize yeah that he
apologize the apology compilation excuse
me it's amazing I will stop your head in
excuse me I got out this was a Christian
family show Oh like what I'm a Christian
and I politic he's just such a [ __ ]
awesome guy all right to me he's awesome
he's like a boundless source of
entertainment and if you knew him man
like if you me and him went out we went
to a bar we had a couple of drinks we
didn't have a great [ __ ] time I'm
telling you no really nice guy he's a
real nice guy and he would start telling
you well the barium they've been putting
barium in the water and you're like why
do you want another beer like it's it's
I'm telling you he's a great guy
but I understand that people are upset
that he has the president's ear and
maybe the presidents like me maybe the
president just thinks he's awesome yeah
crazy story sounds just like ya barium
in the water it sounds great
interdimensional child molesters are
coming in through the cigarette smoke
cigarettes with a 599 chemical they're
designed to let the gates of hell come
loose and interdimensional child
molesters come
and he just will go on and on and on
I love the interdimensional child
molester thing because it's like they
have interdimensional travel
capabilities and they're like immediate
thing like what do we use this for I
know what's brillkids we'll rape kids in
other dimensions you know like what well
there is that really the best
application of that [ __ ] technology
[Applause]
[Music]